it's too many girls in here and action
what do you got it boobs
[ __ ] hate boobs it's not I like like
me a big old man cuz I'm [ __ ] gay I
don't you know if they like talk about
just sell it more like okay body
language like sell it more yeah yeah
okay ready I'm act okay let's go
action I'm gay his father was that good
looks at the camera was that good
don't look at the camera cut know some
gay guy in the bag
I would never no one would ever say that
okay Ron mom saw my apology I'm just you
know I'm still learning we're fine okay
we're fine I'm coming I got it I got it
and action I like dudes a lot good oh I
just just don't say anything
okay got it okay all right okay I can do
that
good all right action
I want to spank that one that one is
slap him right on the ice because he's a
guy and that's what I'm into you know
just gave him a Louisville right across
the butt cheeks oh my god
that's the guy this is great straight
gay dude unconvincing gay dude holiday
time crying holy [ __ ]